acts
11:26 okay and when he found him he
brought him to Antioch so for a whole
year barnabus and Saul met with the
church for an entire year and taught
great number of people the disciples
were called Christians first at Antioch
where if you read the context this is
what's called a Divine passive meaning
they were called Christians by
revelation of God because during this
time there were prophets and apostles
who are receiving Revelation directly
from God and that Revelation they were
enjoying upon Believers for the glory of
the Lord Jesus
Christ how do I know because let's read
the rest of
it acts 11:
27-30 here's the
context acts 11
26-30 but we're going to read 27-30
during this time the time when Paul and
barus were teaching the church in
Antioch Syria for a year where they are
first called
Christians some prophets came down from
Jerusalem to Antioch so notice there are
prophets Apostles and Prophets having
dreams and visions of God or of angels
hearing God audibly revealing to them
the truth of the faith and enjoining
Believers to that truth for the glory of
the Lord Jesus
Christ one of them named agabus stood up
and through the Spirit by the spirit
through the Spirit Holy Spirit revealing
through him predicted that a severe
famine would spread over the entire
Roman
world this happened sees a true prophet
and the spirit knows the future during
the reign of Cl claan let's go a little
deep guys please listen learn your faith
number one you learn the holy spirit is
a
person number two you learn the Holy
Spirit teaches and instructs and number
three you learn the Holy Spirit knows
the future because the Holy Spirit
already warned and prepared Believers in
advance of the famine that would take
place you see how much you learn about
the Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit knows
the future because he's God the Holy
Spirit teaches and instructs and
disciplines and trains and corrects the
church because he's the lord of the
church right and the Holy Spirit is the
one who raises up Apostles and Prophets
through whom he then binds Christians to
that Revelation given to and through
them see
it the disciples good to see him Mr Anam
each according to his ability
decided to provide help for the Brothers
Living in Judea this they did sending
their gift to the elders by Barnabas and
Saul so here's what the text actually
says it does not say they were called
Christians by unbelief belies S as a
derogatory term if you read the context
it is implied they were called
Christians by way of Revelation from the
Lord Jesus Christ from the Trinity
because they are Apostles and Prophets
receiving Revelation from the Triune god
father son holy spirit because when the
spir spirit speaks the son speaks and
the father speaks because in John 16 12-
13 specifically 13 our Lord says that
when the Holy Spirit comes he will not
not speak on his own initiative he'll
only speak what he hears meaning from
the father and the
son so you can make a case contextually
it's the spirit that revealed through
the
apostles and the prophets that Believers
are to be called
Christians identifying themselves as
little Christ or followers of Christ
because they follow obey and worship and
love the Lord Jesus
Christ and now let give you explicit
proof that it was the Lord's will for us
to be called
Christians Mark 9
38-41 I'm giving you the biblical basis
for being called
Christian it is a biblical term given by
revelation of the Lord Jesus Christ do
not be ashamed of that name okay John
said to him teacher we saw a man casting
out demons in your name by your
Authority and we forbade him because he
was not following us but Jesus said do
not forbid him for no one who does a
mighty work in my name will be able soon
soon after to speak evil of me for he
that is not against us is for us pay
attention I'm going to practice now
where do we find the Lord already
indicating we will bear his name and be
identified by our love and fellowship
and devot to him will be
identified by him our Union with him we
will be labeled after him here watch for
Tru I say to whoever gives you a cup of
water to drink because you bear the name
of
Christ will by no means lose his
reward for truly I say to you whoever
gives you a cup of water to drink
because you bear the name of
Christ you bear his name you carry his
name you identifi with him your label
comes from your union with him and if
someone honors you because you bear the
name of the Lord Jesus Christ he'll be
rewarded Mark 9
38-41 now what does it mean to Bear the
name of the Lord Jesus Christ Peter
tells you in an inspired letter written
by a Holy Spirit-filled Apostle here it
is here's what it means to Bear the name
of the Lord Jesus Christ the Bible has
all your answers Brethren you may not
like the answers but the Bible has all
the
answers it is in depth it really is it's
a miracle the Bible the people don't
know that it's a miracle because they
don't understand it or appreciate it or
study it watch here Peter in his first
epistle written by inspiration of the
holy spirit for the glory of the Lord
Jesus Christ he tells you what it means
to Bear In The Name Of The Lord Jesus
Christ 1 Peter 414 and6 here it is an
inspired letter showing you the name
Christian is given to you from the tri
God by way of Revelation if you are
reproached for the name of Christ if you
are rewarded for the name of Christ if
you're insulted in attct because you
Bear In The Name of Christ or if you are
loved and rewarded and appreciated and
aided because you bear the name of
Christ okay if you are report reproach
if people insult you for the name of
Christ you are blessed because this
Spirit of glory and of God rest upon you
let's unpack this guys guys I'm trying
to go in dep as the Holy Spirit enables
me to understand the word and live it
out myself so I don't be a hypocrite he
says if you are being attacked because
you bear the name of Christ you are
happy the word makarios blessed means
happy why because the spirit of glory
and of God rests upon you now what ises
that mean let me tell you what that
means God's spirit rest upon you to
enable and Empower you to endure all
things for the glory of the Lord Jesus
Christ because the spirit has destined
you for
Glory know this is a sign you belong to
the Lord and know this is a sign that
the spirit is working in you to enable
you to endure because the spirit has
destined you for Glory for
glorification to be glorified with the
Lord where you will be made morally
Incorruptible and physically immortal
what the spirit of Glory is God has
given you the Holy
Spirit to preserve you and enable you to
endure till the end because God's
Destiny for you his goal for you is to
be glorified with the Lord Jesus
Christ that's why Peter says be happy
that's a sign for you what's that a sign
of that you are destined to live with
the Lord Jesus Christ in glorified
physical bodies being Immortal and no
more sin no more pain no more misery No
More Death so Rejoice don't be sad don't
be depressed Rejoice be elated that's
your goal because the spirit is
destining you for Glory the spirit is
preserving you for Glory the spirit is
bringing you into Glory but now the
question is what does it mean to be
reproached insulted attacked for the
name of Christ what does it mean to be
loved and aided because you bear the
name of the Lord Jesus Christ the next
verse verse 16 yet if one
suffers as a
Christian yet if one suffers as a
Christian let him not be ashamed but
under that name what name that name you
do what with it what do you do with that
name let him glorify
God wait you mean we have an inspired
letter written by an apostle of the Lord
Jesus Christ who's telling you that you
are to be named
Christian that's your name that's your
identity that's your label and in that
name glorify God do not be ashamed that
you bear that name for the glory of the
Lord Jesus Christ and yet you'll have
Christians who will not use the term
Christian must say I'm a follower of
Yeshua right I'm a follower Yeshua I'm
an
Israelite so did I now established from
scripture the term Christian was not
given to Believers by
unbelievers it was not given by
disbelievers by way of mocking
Christians and it's not a derogatory
term the term the name Christian is
given by God the Triune God the Lord
Jesus already announced you will bear
his name and we're told to bear be's
name is to be called Christian and
glorify the Lord in that name live up to
that name don't bring shame to that name
but glorify the
Lord the Lord hates Division and
sectarianism but sadly we live in a
fallen
world and because of it we are
fragmented disunited sadly may the Lord
Jesus heal this wound in his church and
unify True Believers and I pray we're
all part of that body of believers who
love the Lord Jesus Christ and bring us
to True Union not a fake ecumenism but
let me impact this John said to him
teacher we saw a man casting out demons
in your name but we forbade him because
he was not following us here we have
someone who heard of the Lord Jesus
Christ and believed what he heard about
the Lord Jesus Christ and may have even
seen his miracles and did miracles in
his name but he was not part of the
apostolic band and John said no you
don't do it unless you're part of us
what did our Lord say
but Jesus said do not forbid him for no
one who does a mighty work in my name
will be
able soon to speak after that speak evil
of me once he does miracles in my name
that that means he's convinced I'm the
real Messiah Son of God and that means
he's believing in me otherwise he
wouldn't use my name and authority and
power to do miracles for he that is not
against us is for us what are we to
learn from this Brethren I know it's
going to upset many of you Orthodox many
of you Catholic but I'm trying to be as
honest and may the Lord Jesus save me
from error this teaches us that though
the church is fragmented and divided and
the Lord hates Division and the Lord
wants us to be perfectly United with
truth as our foundation not a fake
ecumenical
Union at the expense of Truth or
compromising truth until the Lord
Returns the sad reality is the true body
of Believers is divided
it's in Schism this is a reminder
whether you like it or not that the Lord
Jesus has True
Believers in all these major branches of
Christianity they may not have the
fullness of
Truth they may not be in the original
church but they are still part of the
body of the Lord Jesus Christ born of
the spirit and they are still being used
by the
spirit to bring
about God's Will and saving the lost in
these major branches of Christianity
even though they're no longer or they do
not know or they're unaware of what the
original church is and that it's been
preserved so let me repeat what I'm not
saying listen let me repeat what I'm not
saying I'm not saying divisions are okay
they're not schisms are okay they're not
there's one body of the Lord Jesus
Christ and there is one Church
historically that was spread over the
world
but sadly because of sin and because of
Satan the church has been fragmented and
until the Lord heals that Schism we must
be humble and realize there are True
Believers in all these major branches of
Christianity born of the spirit who
belong to the Lord Jesus Christ whether
you like it or not and the Lord doesn't
care for your opinion